Elena is with us in Orlando hi Elena how
are you good how are you doing better
than I deserve what's up so I am almost
250,000 dollars in student loan debt
good lord
I'm not even planning on being a doctor
so that's your night are you gonna be a
lawyer no what kind of a degree did you
go get for 250 grand I got my bachelor's
in psychology for trying $15,000 yeah I
think it was a hundred thousand a few
years ago and I didn't even think about
it and then it's just sprang up even
higher but I am planning on going back
to school the social worker and because
everybody knows they make six figures
sure they don't your bro you can't go be
a social worker
what is your what's your household
income right now I'm actually not making
anything
I am a caregiver for my grandma that's
been on this are you single yes okay how
old are you I am 27 okay
mmm this is mean old Uncle Dave on the
line are you ready yeah I'm ready you
have to go make some money get out you
have to go make some money a lot of
money and social workers don't make a
lot of money so you you gave up the
right to be a social worker when you
spent two hundred fifty thousand dollars
on a psych degree so now we have to
retool your career and reset your career
because you need to go make some money
you have a mess on your hands you're
gonna spend the rest of your life as a
slave to this student loan if you don't
I don't want that for you hold on I'm
gonna get you signed up for Financial
Peace University and I'm gonna send you
a book called start but it's not gonna
be start being a social worker this is
the Dave Ramsey show